णमो अरिहंताणं णमो सिद्धाणं णमो आयरियाणं णमो उवज्झायाणं
णमो लोए सव्व साहूणं नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे मंगलं भगवान वीरो,
मंगलं गौतमो गणी। मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो,
जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥ सर्वमङ्गलमाङ्गल्यं
सर्वकल्याणकारकम। प्रधानं सर्वधर्माणां
जैनं जयति शासनम॥ ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः।
कामदं मोक्षदं चैव ॐकाराय नमो नमः पूज्य निहालचंद जी सौगानी जी
के आध्यात्मिक पत्र। पत्र number 22 चल
रहा है।
आज तीसरा
letter है, तीसरा
है। प्रश्न
पूछा था कि किस प्रकार आत्मा
अपनी ओर पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करने का प्रयोग करता है
उसका जवाब चल रहा है
पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि तो पुरुषार्थ सही हो इसके बाद होती है
और पुरुषार्थ सही कहाँ से होता है
जब प्रथम बार आत्मा का अनुभव होता है।
जब प्रथम बार आत्मा का अनुभव होता है वहाँ से पुरुषार्थ सही होता है इसके
पहले अगर योग्य मुमुक्षु है तो
सद्गुरु की आज्ञा अनुसार अपने उल्टे पुरुषार्थ को
सुल्टा करने की कोशिश करता है
लेकिन जब तक final सम्यक दर्शन ना हो जाए तीसरा third सम्यक दर्शन पहला
तो। पहला तो है गुरु की आज्ञा उठाना।
दूसरा है आंशिक रूप से अपने स्वरूप को देख लेना। और तीसरा है
संपूर्ण रूप से निर्विकल्प अपने आत्मस्वरूप को देखना, अनुभव करना।
और तीसरा सम्यक दर्शन जब तक नहीं हुए तब तक कहीं ना कहीं
उसका उल्टा पुरुषार्थ चल रहा।
वो पुरुष... वो पुरुषार्थ को सुलटा करने का प्रयत्न जरूर हो सकता है
योग्य जीव को लेकिन अभी पुरुषार्थ सुलटा हुआ नहीं है
तो अनुभव के बाद। Drawbacks
अनुभव होने के बाद परमात्मा बनने के लिए
एक चाल होती है एक पुरुषार्थ होता है
अगर उसी प्रकार से
चले। अगर उसी प्रकार से चले तो तो जल्दी-जल्दी परमात्मा बन जाते हैं।
इसमें अगर up and downs होवे
तो देर लगती है। लेकिन ये up and downs
होने पर भी वो श्रद्धा का पुरुषार्थ सही होता है,
आचरण का पुरुषार्थ गलत हो सकता है। बाकी के गुणों में
विकृतियां बहुत ज्यादा हो सकती हैं, लेकिन श्रद्धा गुण में विकृति कभी नहीं होती।
और ये मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसी जो श्रद्धा अनुभव पूर्वक है।
वही परमात्मा का बीज है।
ऐसा आत्मा का अनुभव हो इसके लिए अवलोकन बीज है।
और पुरुषार्थ की दृष्टि से। और भावना की दृष्टि से।
मुझे इस दुनिया में कुछ नहीं चाहिए सिर्फ शांति चाहिए
ये भावना का बीज है। चाहिए ये भावना का भेद भावना और पुरुषार्थ
in addition external force में सत्संग सद्गुरु का guidance
ये अगर चार मिल जाए तो आत्मा का अनुभव हो
सकता है। अनंत काल से जो उल्टा हम चल रहे हैं
वो पूरी बाजी पलट सकती है। चार चीज़ चाहिए भावना के भेद चाहिए मुझे शांति के अलावा
कुछ नहीं चाहिए। अलावा कुछ नहीं चाहिए मुफ्त में भी नहीं चाहिए दूसरा
फुर्सत की दृष्टि से सिर्फ अवलोकन करना जानना देखना तीसरा
ये सद्गुरु के personal guidance में रहना
और fourth सत्संग रहना है
ये चार चीज़ें अगर हैं तो आज तक भले
ही हमने अनंत जन्म मरण उल्टे करे। भले हमने अनंत जन्म मरण उल्टे कर लिए
बहुत भटके लेकिन इसका फायदा अपने को पूरी बाजी पलट सकते हैं।
दो internal है भावना और अवलोकन आत्मशक्ति है।
दो external force है सत्संग और सद्गुरु का guidance मार्गदर्शन।
बस इससे पूरी अपनी
एक नई दुनिया खड़ी हो जाती है। इसके बाद सम्यक
दर्शन होने के बाद। सम्यक दर्शन होने के बाद
आत्मा का अनुभव होने के बाद अब पुरुषार्थ कैसे वृद्धिगत करना।
वो अलग chapter है और यहाँ ये chapter की बात चल रही। कि किस प्रकार आत्मा
अपनी ओर पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करने का प्रयोग करता
है। पुरुषार्थ करना हो तो भी आत्मा के दर्शन चाहिए और पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करना हो
तो भी वही है दूसरा कोई उपाय
नहीं है। कौन शरण ही। कौन शरण है इस दुनिया में अपने आत्मा के सिवाय?
इस दुनिया में अपनी आत्मा के सिवाय
कोई शरण नहीं है। हमारा उपयोग बाहर जाता है
तब सद्गुरु के ऊपर नज़र जाती है तब भक्ति होती है तब फिर कहते हैं
कि सद्गुरु ने हमको बचाया।
क्यों बचाया कि अगर सद्गुरु के ऊपर नज़र नहीं जाती तो
आप ही संसार के लफड़े में जाती। बाहर तो निकल ही गए हैं। तो सद्गुरु
ने हमको बचाया मतलब... गुरु ने हमको बचाया मतलब संसार के दावानल से
राग द्वेष से हमको बचाया।
gate पे खड़े थे किसी को अंदर नहीं आने दिए
ना बाहर वाले को अंदर आने दिए। सद्गुरु gate पे खड़े हो गए
ना बाहर वाले को अंदर आने दिए ना मेरे को अंदर से बाहर जाने दिए।
देखो कैसी बात है double काम करते हैं double double है
क्या? नहीं नहीं मुझे तीर। नहीं नहीं मुझे तीर नहीं चलाना है।
कि नहीं तो ये चलाना ही पड़ेगा।
और दूसरा कोई तीर नहीं चलावे इसके ऊपर इसके लिए वो रथ को ऐसा चलाते थे।
कि पूछो नहीं ऐसा। बस सद्गुरु का role देखो कैसा है।
बाहर वाले को अंदर नहीं घुसने
देवे और अंदर वाले को अगर बाहर की ऊँची होवे और जाना चाहे तो नहीं।
Without permission you cannot go. कहें मेरी permission है तो ही जाना बाक़ी
नहीं। कहे मेरी permission है
तो ही जाना, पाठ में किधर
भी जाना और दूसरे का विचार करना है,
किसी की निंदा करना है, कुछ गड़बड़ करना है, मेरे को कुछ बिना नहीं करना।
देखो कैसा है, ये बहुत जबरदस्त role है।
इसीलिए बड़े-बड़े मुनिराज भी जिनेश्वर के समोसरण में जाते हैं।
जो दिन में हजारों बार अनुभव करते हैं ना आत्मा को,
वो भी समोसरण में भगवान के पास तो जाते हैं। नहीं, कितना भी
हम अच्छे हमारे साधना... कितना भी हम अच्छे हमारे साथ ना हो लेकिन आप जैसी नहीं है।
का आप और का हम। दिन में 1000 बार आत्मा का अनुभव होता है।
लेकिन समो शरण में 12 सभा में एक सभा है मुनिराजों
की। दिनेन्द्र भगवान के चरण
कमल में ही रहना है किसको रहना है?
महामुनिराजों को आचार्यों को गणधरों को रहना है उधर दिनेश्वर के चरण में रहना है।
अलौकिक भारत अनुभव होने के बाद जो
जल्दी से परमात्मा बनने की जो चाल है
जो प्रसाद की वृद्धि करना है
उसमें काम तो हमको ही करना है और शरण तो हमारी आत्मा ही है
लेकिन जितना हम अपने से आगे वालों का
बहुमान गुणों की भक्ति अनुराग
ये जितना हम बाहर से करेंगे उतना हम।
जितना हम बाहर से करेंगे उतना हम बचे रहेंगे। ना बाहर वाले हमारे
अंदर आएंगे, ना हम बाहर
जाना चाहें तो भी जा सकेंगे।
ये परम पुरुष के आज्ञा में रहना, परम पुरुष के सानिध्य में रहना,
उनके चरण कमलों में रहना,
ये एक बहुत बड़ा... ये
सौभाग्य होता है तो ही मिलता है नहीं तो
नहीं मिलता। सम्यक दृष्टिकोण आत्मज्ञान होने
के बाद... होने के बाद अभी जो ये भाव पूरा होने के
बाद कभी भी सर्वज्ञ भगवान का भी योग नहीं होगा।
इसका कारण क्या है? यही कारण।
पूर्व में आयुष्य बंध गया और तेज गति में जाना पड़े वो अलग बात है।
लेकिन आयुष्य नहीं बंधा हो तो ये भाव खत्म होते ही
स्वर्ग में जाएंगे और हमेशा सर्वज्ञ भगवान का... सर्वज्ञ भगवान का साथ मिलेगा।
जब चाहे तब जा सकते हैं जहाँ भी आना
हो। 2500 2600 साल पहले मुनिया स्वर्ग से
देवों के टोलियां इस धरती पे आती थी महावीर भगवान की वाणी सुनने के लिए।
देखो आकाश से कितने
करोड़ों इंद्र देव आते थे इधर सुनने के लिए। आकाश से ऐसा आ जाता।
आकाश में ऐसा अलग। भक्ति करते। मनुष्य क्या?
स्वर्ग के देव भक्ति करते हैं। क्यों आए इधर? स्वर्ग में मज़ा नहीं है क्या?
स्वर्ग में मज़ा है लेकिन वो वाणी कहाँ?
वो दर्शन कहाँ जो स्वर्ग में हुए?
ऐसे अकृत्रिम जिन चैत्यालय जिन बिंब है वहाँ पर। एक से एक बढ़िया।
लेकिन साक्षात की बात ही कोई अलग रहती है। हर एक
स्वर्ग में हर एक देव के पास अपना और खुद का personal private बड़ा जिन मंदिर होता है।
जब चाहे तब दर्शन कर लो कहीं बाहर जाने की जरूरत नहीं है। लेकिन प्रत्यक्ष अप्रत्यक्ष।
उसकी तो कोई comparison नहीं है तो ये लोग। स्वर्ग के अपने वैभव को छोड़ कर के
जिनेन्द्र देव को देखने के लिए।
साक्षात परमात्मा को देखने के लिए धरती पे आते हैं क्यों आते हैं? आते
हैं क्यों आते हैं क्योंकि ऐसा करने से और प्रत्यक्ष दर्शन से
पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि होगी।
हमारा आत्मा हमारे पास ही है लेकिन उस पर नज़र करने के लिए आईना चाहिए।
उस पर नज़र करना है तो क्या चाहिए? आईना चाहिए।
और सद्गुरुदेव हिनेंद्र देव क्या है? आईना है। आईना है।
अपना मुँह देखना है तो। तो आईने के सामने खड़े हो जाओ तो अपना मुँह दिखे।
ऐसे पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करनी है तो।
तो क्या करना? सद्गुरु के चरण में रहना।
आईने के सामने खड़े हो जाना।
सद्गुरु की कृपा से सद्गुरु नहीं दिखेंगे,
परम गुरु दिखेंगे। लेकिन कब दिखेंगे? लेकिन कब दिखेंगे
जब आप सद्गुरु के सामने खड़े हो जाएंगे तब।
सद्गुरु से बहुत दूरी थी सौगानी जी को प्रत्यक्ष सत्संग नहीं मिलता था।
लेकिन visualization के द्वारा
वो निरंतर अपने सद्गुरु को साथ में रखते थे।
और उनमें उन पर नज़र पड़ते ही सीधा अंदर आ जाते थे नज़र। रहा है नजर इसीलिए
भक्ति की top level भी सौगानी जी के पास मिलता है
इनकी भक्ति देखो तो
क्या है इसके बिना ऐसी साधना कर ही नहीं सकते भक्ति के बिना नहीं
बताऊँ कैसे बात शब्द देखो
वाव की मतलब सोनगढ़ की धूल के लिए भी तड़पना पड़ता है
गुरुदेव के। गुरुदेव के दृष्टांत अनुसार भक्ति भट्ठी में गिरने का अनुभव
एक दिन में ही मालूम हो गया। सोनगढ़ से बिछड़े वापस कलकत्ता आए और कैसा लग रहा है?
जैसे जमशेदपुर की लोहे की जो भट्ठी रहती है ना कारखाने की उसमें चले गए
हम। एक दिन के अंदर इतना फर्क। धन्य हैं आपके सर्व मुमुक्षु
जिनको सत्पुरुष का निरंतर सहयोग प्राप्त है।
देखिए। मैं अभागी हूँ लेकिन वो लोग धन्य हैं। ऐसा नहीं। दूसरा देखो।
हे गुरुदेव, आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही,
मानो विश्व कीर्तिमोत्तम वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई। उत्तम नहीं, उत्तमोत्तम...
ये राजा नहीं है, राजाओं का राजा, राजाधिराज,
जिसको बोलते हैं, चक्रवर्ती। देव नहीं,
देवों के देव, देवेंद्र। देव नहीं देवों के देव देवेंद्र। देवों के भी इंद्र।
ऐसे उत्तम नहीं विश्व की उत्तम वस्तु नहीं उत्तम में भी उत्तम।
ऐसी वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई है।
नहीं मेरे ज्ञान में अंदर हो गया ध्यान लगाया आत्मा को देखा इसलिए मुझे प्राप्त हुआ।
Credit goes to सद्गुरु। मुझे परमात्मा मिला लेकिन credit goes to सद्गुरु।
सद्गुरु। आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही मानो
विश्व की उत्तम उत्तम वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई। क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ?
यकीन नहीं आता है? मैं पावन मुक्त हो जाऊँगा?
कितने काल से पिंजरे में था शरीर में कैद। अनंत शरीर छोड़ते हैं
वापस दूसरा मिल जाता है। Death होते ही दूसरी जगह जन्म ले लेते हैं। सोते ही दूसरी जगह
जन्म ले लेते हैं। महादेव सोते
ही तीसरी जगह जन्म ले लेते हैं। ऐसा करते-करते अनंत काल से
शरीर की कैद में रहा हूँ।
राग द्वेष की जंजाल में रहा हूँ। एक दुख जावे दूसरा आवे,
दूसरा जावे तीसरा आवे, दुखों के
बवंडर में, समुंदर में घिरा हुआ हूँ। ओहो, अब वो चीज़ मिल गई है,
क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? मुझे यकीन नहीं आता है।
वाह क्या चीज़ मिल गई है। अरे शास्त्रों में जिस मुक्ति की इतनी महिमा बखानी है,
मुक्ति होगी तो ऐसा होगा ना, ऐसा होगा ना।
उसे आपके शब्द मात्र ने इतना सरल कर लिया है।
देखो, सद्गुरु के वचन की तारीफ देखो।
ये जो मैं कल्पना के बाहर था कि मैं कभी
इन जेलखाने में से छुटकारा
मिलेगा। ये जन्म मरण की chain... ये जन्म मरण की channel का कभी अंत आएगा
मुझे यकीन नहीं मुझे सपना भी कभी नहीं आया है।
लेकिन वाह आपके वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही।
मानो विश्व की उत्तमोत्तम वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई। और ऐसा आ गया
ओहो मैं तो मुक्त होने वाला हूँ उसकी खुशी अभी से ही
है। और देखो। सतत दृष्टि। सतत दृष्टि
धारा बरसाते। अखंड चैतन्य के प्रदेश प्रदेश सहज,
महान दीपोत्सव की क्षणे क्षणे वृद्धि करते।
श्री गुरुदेव को अत्यंत
भक्ति भावे नमस्कार। अखंड दृष्टि धारा बरसाते।
श्रद्धा की परिणति छूटती नहीं है। अखंड चैतन्य के प्रदेश प्रदेश सहज,
महान दीपोत्सव की, क्षण... उत्सव की क्षण क्षण में वृद्धि करने वाले।
कौन मेरा ज्ञान नहीं। credit goes to
श्री गुरुदेव की अत्यंत भक्ति भाव है नमस्कार।
और देखो
दरिद्री को चक्रवर्ती बनने की कल्पना नहीं होती।
एक footpath पे रहने वाला मैं चक्रवर्ती बनूँगा वो सपना भी नहीं आता है। भले
चाहना कितनी भी हो। भले चाहना कितनी भी हो लेकिन मेरी life में मैं ऐसा दिन देखूंगा।
उसको सपना भी नहीं आता है। दरिद्री को चक्रवर्ती बनने की कल्पना नहीं होती।
पामर दशा वाले को भगवान हूँ भगवान हूँ ऐसी रटन लगाना।
तो साधारण बात नहीं हे प्रभु ये आप जैसे असाधारण निमित्त काहे का है।
हमारी तो हेसियत औकात ही नहीं है। कि हम बोल सकें कि। कि हम बोल सकें कि हम भगवान हैं।
रटन लगाना तो दूर की बात है।
हम बोल सकें कि मैं भगवान हूँ इतनी भी हमारी औकात नहीं है। लेकिन ऐसे पावन जीव को
आपने ऐसी कृपा कर दी कि अब सतत मेरे को
रटन चल रहा है मैं भगवान हूँ, मैं भगवान हूँ।
ये कोई ordinary निमित्त का काम नहीं है। ये असाधारण निमित्त
का काम है। ये असाधारण निमित्त का कार्य है। वो गुरु की शक्ति है,
गुरु की कृपा दृष्टि है। आज मेरे परिणमन में इतना बड़ा change आया है।
कहाँ चली गई पाखंडता मुझे पता ही नहीं है। सारे दुख दर्द नाम लेते ही मिट गए पूरे।
एक दरिद्री को चक्रवर्ती बनने की कल्पना नहीं होती। लेकिन पाखंड दशा वाले को
भगवान हूँ, भगवान हूँ
की रटन लगाना... की रटन लगाना हे प्रभु आप जैसे असाधारण निमित्त का ही कार्य हो।
और देखो। अतः तीर्थंकर से भी अधिक सत्पुरुष का योग प्राप्त हुआ है।
जिनकी नित्य प्रेरणा। नित्य प्रेरणा कैसे वो तो दूर बैठे थे कहाँ सोनगढ़ कहाँ कलकत्ता।
ये visualization होता था। उस time में VCD नहीं था।
तो। रोज़ cassette नहीं लगाते थे बीच में।
लेकिन गुरुदेव को यहाँ बिठाया था। देखो,
जिनकी नित्य प्रेरणा उधर से विमुख कराकर। उधर से माने? सही सही। जैसे
सद्गुरु बोलते हैं कि क्या सोनगढ़ में रखा है?
जो भी रखा है तेरे पास ही है। क्या मेरे पास है? जो भी है तेरे पास है।
तो उधर से विमुख कराती है। तो उधर से ही मुक कराती है। दिल चाहता है कि वहाँ जाऊँ।
लेकिन फिर गुरुदेव की अंदर से ही आवाज़ आती है कि क्या करोगे यहाँ आकर?
जाना अंदर में, तेरे पास तो है सब।
ऐसा करके वहाँ से वहीं ticket, भाड़ा, traveling सब,
कोई ज़रूरत नहीं है किसी चीज़ की।
जिनकी नित्य प्रेरणा है, रोज़ हमको ऐसा ही बोलते हैं गुरुदेव, अंदर से ही।
अंदर ही बैठे हैं गुरुदेव और
ज़रा भी कुछ भाव आया, सोमनाथ जाना है। कुछ भाव आया सोनगढ़ जाना है। ऐ क्या करते हो?
ध्यान धर। ये नित्य प्रेरणा देखो।
नित्य प्रेरणा उदर से विमुख कराकर स्वयं के नित्य भंडार की ओर लक्ष कराती रहती है।
यहाँ से ही पूज्य गुरुदेव के
न्याय अनुभव सिद्ध होकर दृढ़ता प्राप्त करते हैं। यहाँ से
न्याय निकलते हैं गुरुदेव के।
सोनगढ़ से वो cassette नहीं आती है? क्या?
यहाँ से न्याय निकलते हैं। और... यहाँ से न्याय निकालें। और वो
मेरे न्याय नहीं है, अरे
उनके ही न्याय हैं। taking credit
goes to... नहीं
नहीं गुरुदेव ने न्याय निकाले हैं, मैंने... मेरी कहाँ औकात है?
गुरुदेव ने न्याय निकाला। यहाँ तो
कुछ अच्छे विचार आए तो देखो कितने अच्छे विचार आ रहे हैं।
नहीं पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि नहीं होती है ऐसे। अपने गुण गंभीरता रहना चाहिए,
गुण बढ़े तो छुपा देना
चाहिए। होना चाहिए गुण बढ़े तो छुपा देना चाहिए।
और फिर भी अगर बहुत खुशी होती है तो credit goes to सद्गुरुदेव।
ये हमारी क्या औकात है? वो तो सद्गुरुदेव की औकात है इतनी कृपा है
उनकी शक्ति है तभी ऐसा हो रहा है बाकी हमारे में कोई दम नहीं है।
ऐसा होना चाहिए ये ये सौगानी जी की साधना है सिर्फ। उन्होंने ये
सब बातें नहीं लिखी है इसके अंदर।
लेकिन जहां प्रश्न वो है... प्रश्न वो है।
किस प्रकार आत्मा अपनी ओर पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करता है,
तो मैं उस chapter को भी खोलना चाहता हूँ।
जो उन्होंने अपने हृदय में छिपा के रखा है सौगानी जी।
वो secret रहस्य कृपावदंत भी खोलते हैं।
सौगानी जी नहीं खोलते हैं, ये secret रहस्य है। निरंतर सद्गुरु के चरणों में रहना,
ये सीखना है तो
कृपावदंत। और दृष्टि कैसे लगाना आत्मा में? और दृष्टि कैसे लगाना आत्मा में
ये सीखना है तो सौगानी जी। देखो क्या कहते हैं अब वो तो ये side से बात करेंगे।
दृष्टि के level से बात करेंगे।
कैसे वृद्धि करता है पुरुषार्थ की? अखंड
ज्ञान घन। अखंड माने one piece।
ज्ञान घन माने शक्कर का दृष्टांत दिया था। जैसे शक्कर में मिठास है, सफेदीपना है।
ऊपर में ही नहीं है अंदर में भी है। जैसे ज्ञान घन
ऊपर अंदर सब सब जगह ज्ञान। ज्ञान की मूर्ति है।
पुरुषाकार मतलब देहाकार। आत्मा का जो आकार है वो कैसा है?
देहाकार। पुरुषाकार मतलब स्त्री पुरुष की बात नहीं चल रही है। देह जो है
उस आकार में। ज्ञान की मूर्ति कैसी आकार में है?
कि देहाकार आकार। इसको बोलते हैं पुरुष आकार। शरीर, ये खोखा
दिखने वाला। कर्म, जो अंदर में 8 प्रकार के सारे carbon शरीर हैं।
इसको वेदांत में कहते हैं ना, संचित कर्म, प्रारब्ध कर्म,
क्रियमाण कर्म, ये तीनों कर्मों का एक पोटली अंदर में है।
Invisible। Invisible। ये तो दिखता है लेकिन वो नहीं दिखता है।
जैन भाषा में 8 कर्म कहते हैं ज्ञानावाणी दर्शनावाणी वाली।
उसका बना हुआ एक शरीर है कार्मण शरीर। जो हमको आँखों से नहीं दिखता है।
अनंत काल के राग द्वेष के और अनंत शरीर छोड़कर के जन्म मरण किए हैं और जितना
हमने अच्छे बुरे भाव किए हैं। उसके जो कर्मों का बंधन हुआ है।
वो पूरा download है इधर
कार्मण शरीर। पूरा download है इधर
carbon शरीर के अंदर। Totally अंदर में है गर्भित। कब इसका उदे आएगा पता नहीं।
क्या लेकिन सत्ता में तो है।
File तो अंदर पड़ी है। Computer में जैसे file रहती है वो पड़ी है।
कब खुलेगी पता नहीं। Death की file कब खुलेगी पता
नहीं। बीमारी की file कब खुलेगी पता नहीं।
Lottery कब लगने वाली है पता नहीं। ये भी file अंदर में है।
लेकिन हमको time का नहीं मालूम है कौन से time में क्या होने
वाला है। कब accident होने वाला है
पता नहीं। कब मकान बनने वाला है
पता नहीं। सब अंदर में file पड़ी है total। इसको बोलते हैं carbon शरीर।
तो बाहर में दिखने वाला शरीर अंदर
में... वाला शरीर अंदर में 8 कर्मों का जो शरीर है वो कर्म फिर राग द्वेष के
भाव पल पल में बदलने वाले
कितने 1 second में तो कितने भाव हो जाते हैं
अच्छे हो या बुरे हो इसको बोलते हैं भाव कर्म
द्रव्य कर्म के बाद भाव शरीर कर्म माने द्रव्य कर्म और तीसरा
राग द्वेष में वर्तमान में चलने वाले भाव कर्म और इसके आगे। और इसके आगे
शुद्ध पर्याय। शुद्ध पर्याय माने क्या? आत्मा की ऐसी अवस्था,
कि जहाँ अंश मात्र भी राग द्वेष नहीं हो रहे हैं, उस घड़ी। जैसे हम
ध्यान में बैठे और थोड़ी देर में पूरे भाव चले गए। ना अच्छे ना बुरे।
शांत अवस्था हुई। तो ऐसी जो अवस्था है, उसको बोलते हैं,
शुद्ध पर्याय। शुद्ध पर्याय और ऐसी जब अवस्था होती है तब जीव
जानने देखने में ही रहता है
करने नहीं करने में नहीं रहता
न भूतकाल को याद करता है न वर्तमान के कोई आग्रह होते हैं
न भविष्यकाल की कोई कल्पनाएं होती
हैं जब जानने देखने में रहता है तब शुद्ध पर्याय उत्पन्न होती है
जानने देखने से विपरीत रहना मतलब करना नहीं करना करना
खुराक। करना नहीं करना करना खुराक द्वेष वाले बाबा। और करना धरना छोड़ कर के
जो होवे उसको जानना देखना।
और शून्यता में चले जाना। उसका नाम है। निरविकल्प अवस्था।
इसमें भी अगर आत्मा की दृष्टि होवे तो उसको बोलते हैं। शुद्ध पर्याय।
अब देखो। साधना की वृद्धि कैसे करते हैं।
तो साधना की वृद्धि कैसे करना है। कि आत्मा को जिस
प्रकार से। कि आत्मा को जिस प्रकार से देख कर के
सही पुरुषार्थ किया। वही बार-बार देखना आत्मा को।
तो उसको साधना की वृद्धि हो, पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि हो। कैसा है आत्मा?
अखंड है। ज्ञान घन है। पुरुषाकार है। शरीर से,
आठ कर्मों से, अंदर के राग द्वेष के भावों से,
और शून्यता से। Blankness। Blankness जो आती है वो, उन सबसे
भी उंदा, उन सबसे अलग, ये सब के अंदर में, भीतर में।
नीचे नहीं, भीतर। भीतर में और नीचे में फर्क है।
भीतर और नीचे में कितना फर्क है?
बहुत फर्क। गहराई। गहराई। हाँ, ये
उंदा की बात करते हैं कि आत्मा कहाँ है? के शरीर... के शरीर कर्म
भाव कर्म और blankness शुद्ध पर्याय
उनके अंदर गहराई में और गहराई में जाओ उससे भी ऊँडा
चैतन्य तत्व मैं हूँ
चैतन्य तत्व है ऐसा नहीं लिया ऐसा बोलते तो गड़बड़ होती क्या देखिए
कितना। क्या? देखिए कितना फर्क है, एक शब्द में कितना फर्क पड़ गया है।
शरीर, कर्म, भाव कर्म और शुद्ध पर्याय से भी उंडा चैतन्य तत्व है।
नहीं, ये बात नहीं है। नहीं, पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि कैसे करना है? प्रश्न वो है।
तो गड़बड़ हो गई।
फर्क देखना क्या है? शरीर, कर्म, भाव कर्म और शुद्ध पर्याय से भी
उंडा... शुद्ध पर्याय से भी उंडा
चैतन्य तत्व है नहीं ऐसा नहीं
शरीर कर्म भाव कर्म व शुद्ध पर्याय से भी उंडा
चैतन्य तत्व मैं हूँ कितना change हो गया
कितना change हुआ first sentence के अंदर
वो जैसे दूसरे आत्मा की बात चल रही है। और second sentence में।
ये मैं ऐसा। स्वयं। स्वयं। कितना फर्क पड़ गया?
बहुत बड़ा फर्क पड़ा। शरीर, कर्म, भाव कर्म
व शुद्ध पर्याय से भी, उड़ा, चैतन्य तत्व,
मैं, हूँ। ढूंढना है,
खोजना है, देखना है, कैसे देखोगे?
आँखों से। कैसे सुनोगे? कानों से।
कैसे सोचोगे? मन से। कभी नहीं मिलेगा।
मैं हूँ, ये अनुभव का विषय
है। ये अस्तित्व का ग्रहण करना है। उंदा मतलब भीतर
और गहराई में चैतन्य माने जानने देखने वाला
वाला मत कहो
ज्ञान दर्शनमयी चैतन्य और तत्व
तत्व माने क्या कि इस world में जितने भी पदार्थ हैं तत्व। तत्व
उसका त्व छाछ का मक्खन पदार्थों का सार
या cream इस पूरे world के अंदर cream क्या चीज़ है
top most चीज़ क्या है ये जानने देखने
वाली चैतन्य ज्ञान दर्शनमयी चैतन्य। चैतन्य तत्व
सब तत्वों का राजा सब तत्वों का सार मैं
हूँ अभी पूरा नहीं हुआ वचन देखो अभी आगे देखना कैसा concentrate कराते हैं
फिर से
अखंड ज्ञान
घन पुरुषाकार। अखंड का
one piece कि यहाँ
brain में या हृदय में ऐसा नहीं।
पांव में vibration होता है तो वहाँ ऐसा नहीं। सर में होता है तो वहाँ
ऐसा नहीं।
अखंड one piece। ज्ञान धन।
पूरा ज्ञान से भरा हुआ खाली नहीं है कुछ। Blankness है
लेकिन वो blankness है वो आत्मा नहीं। Blankness में तो खालीपना है।
और ये तो... और ये तो खाली थोड़ा है।
शक्कर की मिठास खाली है कि अंदर ऊपर है अंदर खाली है
कि? शक्कर में हर जगह मिठास है। ऐसे ज्ञान घन।
खाली नहीं है blankness तो वो blankness को देखने वाला ज्ञान घन। कोई मा... फोकट
की zero चीज है शून्यता है। Zero चीज़ है, शून्यता है, ऐसा कुछ नहीं है,
ज्ञान घन है। पुरुषाकार ये क्षेत्र बताया है।
लेकिन इस area में देखते हैं तो
शरीर दिखता है, कि नहीं वो नहीं,
शरीर नहीं। अंदर देखते हैं तो कर्म दिखते हैं, कि नहीं वो नहीं।
और अंदर जाते हो, राग द्वेष के भाव दिखते हैं, कि नहीं वो भी नहीं। और अंदर जाते हो,
तो blankness आती है, कि नहीं वो भी नहीं। फिर क्यों?
इससे भी गहरा... इससे भी गहराई में हम कौन अब कह नहीं सकते।
क्योंकि शब्दों से पार है वो।
इसलिए ये नहीं, ये
नहीं, ये नहीं, ये
नहीं। शरीर
नहीं, कर्म नहीं। भाव कर्म नहीं।
शुद्ध पर्याय नहीं। फिर कौन? वो कह नहीं सकते।
उससे भी गहरा है, चारों से भी गहरा। कुंडा।
अब अध्याय हो जाएगा। गुंडा। अबाध्य अनुभव जे रहे तेसे जीव सरो।
बात करता करता।
ये नहीं, ये नहीं, ये नहीं, ये नहीं। और फिर कौन? नहीं इससे
भी अंदर गहरा, लेकिन कैसा?
वो कह नहीं सकते। फिर भी एक बार लिखा है, चैतन्य तत्व।
जानने देखने वाला।
जानने देखने वाले।
अब तो ठीक है ना? नहीं अभी भी ठीक नहीं है। चैतन्य तत्व ठीक नहीं है।
शरीर, कर्म, भाव कर्म, शुद्ध पराय से भी, उंडा, चैतन्य तत्व।
ठीक? नहीं अभी भी ठीक नहीं है। ठीक है वो तो दूसरों की बात हो मैं हूँ
मैं अपनापन हूँ अस्तित्व हाज़िर है जैसे कि सामने देख रहा हूँ visualize कर रहा हूँ
feel कर रहा हूँ
सामने नहीं अपने में feel
कर रहा हूँ मैं हूँ यही मेरा अस्तित्व है अभी भी वाक्य पूरा नहीं हुआ है मैं हूँ के
बाद comma आप कहते हैं यही। अब कहते हैं यही मेरा
अस्तित्व है, इतना ही
मैं हूँ। यही मेरा जो भी है, यही है।
मेरा घर, मेरा flat, मेरा बंगला, मेरी ज़मीन, यही है।
जो कभी जाने वाली नहीं है, कोई चुराने वाला नहीं है।
कोई ले नहीं सकता है, अग्नि जला नहीं सकती है।
पानी भिगा नहीं सकता है, पवन उड़ा के ले नहीं आ सकता है,
तलवार काट नहीं सकती है,
वो कोई ये मैं। क्या? ये
मैं। यह यही यह मेरा अस्तित्व नहीं, यह ही मेरा अस्तित्व है।
इतना ही है,
साथ में शरीर मेरा कहते हैं तो व्यवहार से कहते हैं।
राग द्वेष तुम करते हो तो व्यवहार से।
ये वेदना मुझे आया ये व्यवहार से है, मेरे को वेदना नहीं आ सकता है।
मैं तो वेदना से भी हूँ गहरा हूँ। और हम वेदना की चाहना करते हैं तो कितने मूर्ख हैं।
वेदांत... वेदन तो... वेदन नहीं आ रहा है। अरे भैया कपार तेरा।
क्या वेदन के पीछे पड़े हो? परमात्मा होकर के भीख मांगते हो? शर्म नहीं आती है?
वेदन नहीं आ रहा
है। नहीं आया तो
नहीं आया है।
लेकिन बंद क्यों हो गया? अरे
हो गया तो और ज्यादा। तू थोड़े बंद हो गया है। तू देख अभी अंदर में। वो
तो बंद होने वाला है क्योंकि वो तेरा नहीं था। वो... वाला है क्योंकि वो तेरा नहीं
था वो permanent रूप नहीं था
तेरा। ये permanent ये है यही यही
मेरा अस्तित्व है। देख वो है कि नहीं है वेदन माया होली कि वो है कि नहीं है देख।
वो है कि नहीं है यही मेरा अस्तित्व है। अभी वाक्य पूरा नहीं हुआ।
अब कहते हैं। तो वेदन क्या था
कि वेदन का क्या हुआ? कोई प्रश्न पूछेगा भई वेदन तो नहीं आ रहा ना? वेदन का क्या हुआ?
उसका answer। शुद्ध पर्याय का अस्तित्व भी इसमें गौण है।
clear कर दिया उस बात को।
भैया वेदन भले ही आवे या नहीं आवे लेकिन वो उसके अस्तित्व में वेदन नहीं होगा।
और गौण कहाँ है? गौण इसलिए कहा है, कि जब वो तत्व के ऊपर नज़र जाएगी ना,
कैसे तत्व के ऊपर शरीर से भिन्न कर्म से भिन्न
भाव कर्म से भिन्न
शुद्ध पर्याय से भिन्न का मतलब क्या कि अपेक्षा छोड़ देना वेदन में
जब तक अपेक्षा है तब तक आप भिन्न नहीं हो
शुद्ध पर्याय से भिन्न का मतलब क्या
देखना है आत्मा को वेदन आवे तो अच्छा है वेदन आवे तो अच्छा है। आराम से। अच्छा बैठो,
ध्यान से बैठो। अभी आएगा, देखो अभी आएगा। आ जाएगा। ये भिन्नता नहीं है ये।
ये आत्मा का ध्यान नहीं है, ये वेदन का ध्यान है। किसका ध्यान है?
गजब है। ये पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि नहीं होती, उल्टी down हो जाता है, downfall आता है।
पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि कैसे होती है? ये प्रश्न ये है,
पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि कैसे होती है? देखिए क्या... देखिए क्या
कमाल रखा है इसके अंदर। गजब का है इसके अंदर। एक शब्द
भी फर्क पड़ गया। हाँ बहुत फर्क पड़ गया। सुपरिया का अस्तित्व भी
इसमें गलत है। ऐसा भी लिख दिए तो
गलत है। तरबंदा। सुपरिया
से भी उंडा। जब ऐसे उंडे चेतन तत्व
के ऊपर मैं हूँ ऐसा अपनापन होगा,
तो क्या होगा?
वेदन नहीं आएगा? वेदन तो अपने आप... वेदन आएगा। नहीं आएगा। आएगा अपने आप
आएगा। वो तो अपने आप आएगा।
तो फिर क्या कहते हैं? कि यही मेरा अस्तित्व है माने वेदन बिना का जो तत्व है ना,
जिसमें मैंने अपनापन किया, वो मेरा अस्तित्व है।
लेकिन साथ में ये भी जो वेदन आना शुरू हो गया है ना, वो क्या है? कि नहीं वो गौण है।
वो boundary के बाहर है, मेरे में नहीं है। ये clear कर दिया।
Clear करने में ये बात बता दी उन्होंने कि जब यहाँ
main तत्वों के
ऊपर नज़र जाएगी ना, तो वेदन 100% होगा होगा और
ऐसा कभी नहीं बनता है,
कि आपका केंद्र स्थान में आपका तत्व हो, चैतन्य तत्व, नज़र वहाँ टिकी हो,
Goal setting कर दिया हो, और आपको वेदन नहीं आवे, ऐसा बंद। आपको वेदन नहीं आवे
ऐसा बन नहीं सकता है। वेदन आएगा भी
और आप उसको गौण भी करना है।
वेदन आएगा भी। आप मना करोगे तो भी आएगा।
आप बोलोगे बंद हो जाओ, नहीं बंद नहीं होने वाला है, आएगा ही आएगा। क्यों?
बंद करना है तो नज़र हटा दो केंद्र स्थान से।
आत्मा से नज़र हटा दो और वेदन के पीछे भागो,
वेदन बंद हो जाएगा। आओ वेदन बंद हो जाएगा। वेदन बंद करना
आसान है बहुत। पर हम इसमें तो master हैं।
हम लोग सब बहुत master हैं। वेदन को बंद करने में तो माहिर हैं।
लेकिन अगर वेदन को continue रखना है, तो रख सकते हो।
फुर्सत की वृद्धि कर सकते हो।
आसानी से कर सकते हो। Normally ऐसा check करते
हैं वेदन नहीं आ रहा है। मतलब ध्यान नहीं हो रहा है
check... मतलब ध्यान नहीं हो रहा है checking point पे
इधर उधर। हाँ हाँ हाँ। बहुत गलत। ये एक तो भूसा है जो सौगानी जी को नहीं
था। आश्चर्य की बात है कि सद्गुरु के सामने नहीं होते वो भी कैसे कैसे निकली बात
समझ में? ये अंदर से निकली और credit goes to गुरुदेव। कैसी भक्ति
ये भक्ति का प्रताप है।
ये अंदर से निकलने के बाद क्या कारण क्या है? ये अंदर की भक्ति थी।
जो किसी को दिखाई देती नहीं थी ऐसी भक्ति।
लेकिन भक्ति की। जबरदस्त। ज्ञान खोल देती है। और
ज्ञान को clarity को
निर्मलता ला देती है भक्ति।
भक्ति वो
चारनी है छरनी छरनी बोलते हैं ना क्या
बोलते हैं। कचरा पूरा बाहर और अंदर
सीधा फिर और ज्ञान जावे।
ज्ञान में जो दूसरा कचरा है ना। Filter। और filter filter।
Correct। This is white। Correct, this is right. यही सोच रहा था चार नहीं वचन बोल रहा
था। Double refined, triple refined. या ये अनंत refine है भक्ति।
भक्ति तलवार है। भक्ति दर्पण है, क्या क्या बोल सकते हैं भक्ति को?
सिर्फ भक्ति ही मुक्ति है। भक्ति ही शक्ति है। वो filter होकर के
जो disturbed ज्ञान होता है वो भक्ति के द्वारा
filter होकर के एक... Filter होकर के एक बार नहीं दो बार नहीं अनंत बार refine होकर के
pure आता है ज्ञान अंदर। ज्ञान में से ये सब निकलता है।
क्या कहते हैं? कि जब मूल तत्व के ऊपर नज़र जाएगी ना।
तो वेदन को बंद करना चाहोगे
तो वो बंद नहीं होगा। कितना भी रोको नहीं रोके नहीं रुकेगा
अगर आपकी नज़र तत्व के ऊपर रहेगी तो।
तो फिर क्या करना उसको अपना अर्थित्व में शामिल करना।
खबरदार किया है तू।
मुनियाज को सभी कल्प स्वसंवेदन 24 hours रहता है।
लेकिन मुनियाज को मालूम है कि मेरी boundary के बाहर हो रहा है मेरे में नहीं हो रहा
तभी तो
चल रहा है नहीं तो चलता ही नहीं था इतना। शामिल
करना उस time ये सब विकल्प नहीं थे। सबको ये समझ में
नहीं आ रहा था। उस time नहीं लेकिन बाद में तो होते हैं।
और बाद में होते हैं उसमें पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि नहीं होती।
उसके बाद अगर वो जाने के बाद उस time तो कितना देते हो?
बाद में कचरा बहुत है। बाद में बोलते हैं एक second के बाद की बात है। एक समय के बाद
एक समय अंदर रहते हो क्यों दो समय
नहीं रहते? समय अंदर रहते हो क्यों दो समय नहीं रहते हो क्योंकि ये कचरा
है इसलिए। दो समय कचरा
है। गाड़ी कैसे चले carbon घुस जावे तो अंदर। साफ कराओ plug।
गाड़ी चलेगी।
carbon आ गया तो कैसे होगी गाड़ी?
गाड़ी रुक जाती है बार-बार। तो ये कचरे के कारण रुकती है।
और यहां clear कर दिया है कि शुद्धि करना है तो। 24 hours सविकल पेदन हो सकता है।
आखिरी ताकत है। खास तौर पे जब समाधि मरण का time आता है।
तब तो धड़धड़ाट ही हो जाती है। सभी कल्प की क्या वो तो निरिकल्पता में चले जाता है।
क्योंकि वो तो do or die रहता है फिर तो फिर तो कोई chances नहीं
है। अभी करो या बाद में कल करना है वो बात नहीं रहती अभी करना पड़ता है।
On the spot करना पड़ता है। वो तो लड़ाई का रण रण मैदान में आ गए हो।
उस time में अगर आप बोलो कि नहीं थोड़ा time है थोड़ा अच्छा सोचूँ विचारूँ,
नहीं विचारने का time नहीं है, उस time
तो 1 2 3 करो। थोड़ा उसको ये सलाह दे दूँ उसको ये कह दूँ कि नहीं ये चलेगा ही नहीं।
इसीलिए अगर 4 दिन 5 दिन पहले अगर मृत्यु आने वाली है पक्का हो जाए तो क्या साधना बढ़ती
बहुत जबरदस्त साधना बढ़ती है। उसमें भी शरीर में वेदना होवे।
उसमें भी उठ भी नहीं सके क्योंकि उठे तो चेहरा पूरा काट रखा है,
काट दिया है ना, कैसे उठाओगे? ऐसा
ऐसा भी change नहीं कर सकते आप, ऐसी हालत होवे तो।
नलियां लगी हुई हो तो। visualize करना उस situation में क्या होता है।
जो अंदर में साधना है
उस time में जवाब दे देगी। यहां अच्छे बच्चों का पानी पसीना निकल जाता है।
वीर वीर।
वीर वीरता का काम है। जैसे वैसों
का काम नहीं। ये जो अल्प भाव में दो चार भाव में मोक्ष जाने वाले
हैं, क्या वो leader का काम है?
ऐसे time पर तो वो एक ही शरण मात्र है। ऐसे time में नहीं हर वक्त वो एक ही शरण है।
जो हर वक्त ऐसी शरण लेता है,
वो ऐसे time पे ले सकता है। वो ऐसे time में ऐसे शरण में रहता है। एक तो नहीं ले सकता।
क्या? क्या? सोचते हैं कि समय बीत रहा है। नहीं नहीं, हम बीत रहे हैं।
ऐसा समझकर जो जी रहे हैं, वो जंग जीत रहे हैं।
समय नहीं बीत रहा है, हम बीत रहे हैं। ये हर पल याद रख कर के जो
जी रहे हैं, वो मैदान-ए-जंग में
जीत रहे हैं। सबकी बात नहीं है, वीरों की बात
है। नहीं है। विरलों की बात है। ये तो सूर्य का भाव है, सूर्यता का भाव।
Josh आ जाते हैं। Do or die, आप कौन आता है सामने? एक मोर नहीं टिकने देते हैं,
एक मोर नहीं, सब आपकी cutting हो जाएगा वहां पर।
सुत परे है, हद नहीं चाहिए सुत परे है।
उठा के फेंक देंगे बाहर भेदन में। और फिर क्या वेदना आवे? और क्या मस्ती होवे?
भले ही आवे, मेरे boundary के बाहर है। मेरे boundary के बाहर है
मेरे में नहीं है
ऐसी प्रथम
यथार्थ श्रद्धा जब ही कही जाती है कि ऐसी श्रद्धा के प्रसार के साथ लीनता का प्रथम
आत्मा का अनुभव होता है पूरी बातें तो हम भी बोल करके
कर देंगे ऐसा नहीं चलता
है। पता नहीं चलता है
आपको इस प्रकार का अनुभव हुआ है जब आप ऐसे
त्रिकाली ध्रुव को लक्ष्य में रखते हो तब आपको ऐसे वेदन का अनुभव होता है
और होता है तो भी आप उसको गौण रखते हो
आपका दृष्टि का दौर कहीं फिसलता तो नहीं है
उसको कहीं शामिल तो नहीं करते हो ना शुद्ध पर्याय को अपने में।
अगर शामिल किया तो श्रद्धा बराबर नहीं।
शुद्ध पराय को वेदन को शामिल किया तो
श्रद्धा बराबर नहीं। बाहर क्या होता है वो कोई important नहीं है
लेकिन श्रद्धा कैसे किया है
वो थोड़ा important है। इसी इसी point के ऊपर तो
हरि भाई को निकाल दिया गुरुदेव ने। 32 साल पानी में गए।
हटाओ यहां से। आतंक धर्म बंद कर दो कोई नहीं लिखता है।
लेकिन ये नहीं चाहिए हमारे को एक भी
वेदन को शामिल किया। वेदन को शामिल किया आत्मा में।
नहीं चाहिए, get out. पहले पूछा भई गलती से लिखा है,
मेरे मानने में नहीं आता है, तुमने गलती से लिखा हो।
मैंने तो ऐसा प्रवचन में कहा नहीं। कि नहीं,
correct है जो लिखा है। तूने अपना मिलाया है मेरी बात में, तूने अपना मिला दिया है।
प्रवचन तुम मेरे लिखते हो, छापते हो और तूने अपना... छापते हो
और तूने अपनी बात मिला दी। माफ़ी मांग लो।
और change करो ये statement। नहीं मैंने जो भी लिखा है बराबर लिखा है।
आत्मा के अनुभव के वक्त ऐसा ही होता है। या तो
मेरे नज़र के सामने 32 साल से जिसने सेवा की निस्वार्थता से।
इतने बड़े-बड़े ग्रंथ लिखे गए। नहीं
तारीफ भी इतनी की है कि इनके जैसा कोई लिखने वाला नहीं मिले। नहीं मिले। जब
उठाया जब एक second में उठाया।
परमागम sir मंदिर में एकदम खड़ा कर दिया उसको। बोलो क्या करते हो?
सबके सामने बोलो अब जो भी बोलना है अपन।
मेरे room में आके बोले ऐसा नहीं चलता यहाँ बोलो। कभी भी सुधर जाओ।
Get out. गुर्दे की ताकत क्या है इसी point के ऊपर तो है।
उस time में मैं ही था उधर 75 में। 75 में परमागम मंदिर में फंगड़ में।
क्योंकि उन्होंने वेदन को अपने अस्तित्व में शामिल किया।